hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to another episode of get close I'm your
co-host Geo and I'm Bart and I just
finished sneezing so I feel a little
snuffle snuffle yeah you got a lot of
gold on holy [__] is that real oh yeah
baby didn't you know we're rich dude I
forgot no [__] we're rich baby how
rich is that 200 uh no maybe like 10
bucks
that's real Rich yeah no I don't even
it's not gold at all it's probably like
plated spray painted this color okay I
have a question for you and it's a
[__] loaded question so are you
trying to have a good day or a bad day
always
which one there's two options does it
matter always to both you're open to any
possibilities I'm always ready to date
all right let's do it I had to write
this down because I try to come prepared
and I try to write topics for all of our
podcasts before we meet yeah
are you ready yeah okay
if I had to change a few things to make
me the most perfect the most ideal
partner
that you ever had yeah
you [__] son of a [__] your [__]
answer should have been nothing I'm
perfect already I'm the most ideal I'm
everything you ever dreamed of if I was
a liar yeah yeah no I know but yeah and
you can't [__] say nothing because
that's [__] yeah of course isn't
that why would I lie you know what yeah
I haven't even thought about this
question myself good I'd like write them
down and I haven't given it any thoughts
so I'm so glad you're going first okay
because I have no idea all right so do
we want to go with the physical the
mental the biological
let's start top to bottom so let's go
okay with the mental all right so top to
bomb first thing in the head compartment
in the head compartment I would say the
first one
you got to get rid of all those white
hairs you got too many white hairs off
no no no come on be serious are you
serious yeah you swear to God if I were
to make you perfect
swear to God yeah
yeah my smarts or some [__] something
that mattered to you only we're only
going physical no you said we're going
ahead so I'm gonna go out out to end oh
okay okay so on the outside I'll take
all these you have like this oh so we
going like that [__] you
literally said dude you said top the
bottom I did but I meant it not like in
a literal sense that's one [__]
thing I change about you
so you said top to bottom yes I'm taking
notes Outside Inside take [__] too
you're writing notes I am
I told you I didn't think about it
okay go all right top to bottom in your
head too much white hairs you gotta get
rid of that [__] I don't swear yeah okay
cool that's disgusting
no are you [__] around I'm not
[__] around do you think it's
disgusting I don't care but if I had the
option to change like why wouldn't I and
you think it's disgusting I don't think
it's disgusting you literally just said
it's disgusting and I said are you
serious and you said yes rolled off my
tongue after I said I wanted to change
it okay can we speak uh this is another
one I would change about you [__] can we
speak clear English I am speaking clear
English can I can I also not be in the
moment you can but if you're gonna use
the word disgusting have you ever been
to Europe didn't I tell you you're about
to have a good day or a bad have you
ever been to Europe I have you know like
sometimes you're at the bar right
[__] Great Britain scores you're like
yeah and you just go it's like it just
rolled off the tongue you don't mean
anything by it but two people just kiss
that's it it's just no that doesn't
happen it just rolled off the top roll
off the tongue it rolled off the tongue
I looked at your hair I was like what
the hell is that that's disgusting
nothing buy it it just rolled off the
tongue how many roll off the tongue
kisses have you had [__] I've
only been to Europe a couple times not
even in Europe how many [__] cut roll
off the tongue kisses have you had
honestly maybe like two or three I swear
I swear to God with whom I'm not gonna
tell you
are we focusing on what we would change
or no
it's happening you've really had to roll
off the tongue kisses can we stay on
topic Jesus [__] Christ what the [__]
is going on
now that we now that you showed me all
your cavities maybe change some of those
cavities too
holy [__] looks like a construction zone
in there
listen you [__] is that rebar is that
Foundation all right [__] you not
everyone can have a [__] underbite
and jacket teeth like your [__]
I thought it was my
turnout cavities or [__] what is it
caps fillings or something they're both
of them because you're hurting mine okay
just take it okay fine but is it my turn
or your turn no it's your turn okay so
you said the white hairs okay white
hairs right yeah cavities what did I ask
you I did what go go ahead cavities I
don't have cavities whatever the [__]
those things are okay well then be
descriptive dude use your word oral
anvils I don't know what the [__] they
are do what with it do what with it
what does that mean clean it up use your
words not so clean it up I'm
communicating with you [__]
okay go ahead I would say wrinkles but
I love how long we've been together and
I want to keep them because those are
beautiful memories no [__] you none of
this [__] means anything anymore with
the other two statements all this other
[__] you're talking you're having a bad
day just letting you know I'm just being
honest can I be honest uh at your own
risk dude okay here's a side note okay
for every guy listening no you shut up
right now right you've talked too
Goddamn much for every guy listening
this is the Trap that women set for you
yes and you stupid [__] not all
of you because not everyone is like Bart
yeah he's a stupid [__] and he
walks right into it whistling yeah he's
just so stupid
ask you have to you have to say you
would change nothing at all
I'll tell you what what
if I was a mouse and you said a mouse
trap I'm grabbing that cheese yeah cause
you're stupid exactly of course and I'm
gonna be the guy with the mouse trap
stuck to me for the rest of my life
because that's my style yeah alone you
ready no [__] food no mate with your
[__] neck all jacked up and twisted
that's gonna that's how you're gonna end
up dude one of a kind there's no other
mouse that walks around like that
there's a ton of you dude how many
mouses [__] rock I've been around the
block all right I know a lot of mices in
Europe in Europe in Europe go all right
so the wrinkles you'll keep them keep
them because I love that I love how you
was like a bad cat this this year is our
15th year together and I think that's
[__] beautiful
this is where it ends we're not gonna
see 16 if you continue this podcast
that's [__] beautiful okay so now
that's on the outside
it's so far you're losing two to one you
got you got the white hairs and you got
the cavities but then you got the
wrinkles I don't have cavities two to
one you're losing okay it sounds like
it's three to zero honestly from this
end let's go on the inside let's take a
deep dive on the inside there's nothing
else on the body we're gonna go top down
he said I'm just following your
destruction
so we're at the top I'm gonna go outside
inside okay go down Outside Inside okay
go right that's literally what you just
said holy [__] go
okay going inside
gotta fix that whatever dyslexia you got
going on in there okay when you say left
you mean right when you mean freezer you
mean microwave I don't know what the
hell you're talking about okay number
two we gotta get rid of that [__]
attitude got attitude problem feisty
something happens count with the strike
back oh yeah jump to conclusions it's in
my Latina but we don't even know what's
happening even having enough Clues and
you're just [__] just punching the
air for no reason yep I'm [__] ready
right there
yeah right there okay
also love that I just not love [__] you
all right This Is War tell me the [__]
you want to change I don't give a [__]
change that change that okay change What
attitude that's your problem I love it
okay I love how much of a Clear Vision
you have in your that's it
going down
going down to this part right here okay
the Torso okay the shoulders the neck
down to the waist
something around there gets cold real
easy I don't know what the [__] it is
I don't like I don't like all that
temperature [__] we gotta get you warm
somehow
you got that
that's good right there in the center
right below your titties
24 7 bubble guts don't know what the
[__] that is
not bubble guts
a lot of [__] fatty food eat a
chimichanga going straight to the toilet
five seconds later don't know what the
[__] going on but you got some [__]
bubble guts right there
we got a [__] fix that share right
there all right I got another one
oh my God
also you got those two hands right two
very capable hands it'd be nice if you
use those two hands to take more showers
all right
you're gonna scrub around a little bit
more you know you got two hands nope you
take you take shots like you only have
one hand but you got two of them I want
to take showers like I have no hands all
right all right that shit's too much
work it's too cold you know what I mean
it's just all intertwined like it's not
happening okay now going down to the
bottom from the waist down to the toes
you got stinky feet you gotta give her
that sneaky feet no I don't what are you
talking about ask taika he smells your
feet more than I have now I do you
and he always goes yeah because he's
five dude
he's five
what does that mean yeah it's an honest
joke no no no no no that it's a funny
joke hey
you're making it sound like you could
smell my feet and you cannot that's
[__] you can't smother from here
that's not stinky feet then what are you
talking about so I just have regular
body odor is that what you're talking
about I don't know is it my turn to
change you or what go for it I'm gonna
change all that okay I'm gonna change
that
um I love the way your [__] looks I'm
not gonna change your [__] it's
beautiful you have a beautiful [__] oh
no you got beautiful [__] okay
but that's it
I [__] hate you you asked me this
question that's it that's all I'm Gonna
Change that's it
yeah really yeah now I feel bad it's not
even though why you got a whole big old
list holy [__] well maybe didn't maybe
just lay it on me then
um honestly I don't even have that long
of a list
so like so physically for me I think I
would need to just a whole different man
I agree
I honestly agree
who would you go with
The Rock just kidding The Rock no not
the rocky skin looks weird because if
all six four
we're on the same page
I don't even know okay okay so if you
were my ideal you would probably be
taller for sure you'd probably be like
two or three inches tall if I was my
ideal I'd be taller for sure yeah
uh you would for sure be taller for me
yeah not to say that that's what I seek
right again kind of what you're telling
me right like it's not something that
you care to even change it's not a deal
breaker it's not any of that it's not
even anything we think about but now
forced with this question in front of us
then we think of the ideal then yeah
that would be like a moon roof right
you're not even thinking about it and
then you're at the car dealership and
they're like hey just let you know this
car for some reason from the factory
yeah you can have a moon roof and no
extra cost exactly exactly yeah [__] let
me get it let me get the room yeah
that's what that's what we're talking
about so you would be you would be a
minimum six two
um uh on the outside so that's more of
the physical side
um top down too or no
uh if you want me to do you want me to
whatever style you put that style on me
so I was just okay I'll just I'll just
do the head then okay I'll do on the
head
um
so I would probably do a lot more
moisturizing on the face really what's
wrong with my face it's [__] dry and
it looks painful as [__] and it just
looks like it looks painful it doesn't
look painful because it's so dry like
it's red it has all these different
colors like you just need to just
moisturize I do I do need to make the
colors take care of your face a little
bit more yeah yeah
um I would do that yeah I would for sure
reinstate some either braces
um oh for us yeah should I move back
yeah I would probably suggest brushing
your teeth more I brush it twice a day
you know you know that yeah maybe and I
floss too yeah I mean your breath has
gotten a lot better than how it once was
yeah because that she was intolerable
she tolerated then I mean we didn't kiss
very much did we we did we used to kiss
way more
because more than we do now uh I would
probably yeah reinstate some braces
um probably even get some veneers going
just because your teeth you want me to
[__] shave my [__] down and get
veneers on so it looks pretty perfect
yeah I like perfect because I could
totally do that well I'm not I don't
need you to go out and do what I'm
asking I don't need you to [__] get
bone lengthening surgery yeah like I'm
not gonna take more showers you know
what I mean like it's just a
conversation absolutely not God damn
we're married we have a kid who am I
trying to impress hopefully me no dude
all right not at all
um I would do that so like the clearing
of the skin
taking showers
it's a big [__] Fiasco so one do you
want me to explain that do you want to
get sidetracked do you want me to
continue with yeah tell me why you only
take like two showers a week
um so one my hair for sure I'm not
trying to wet my hair more than maybe
once or twice a week why it breaks it's
like bleaching it is the worst thing you
can do for your hair it's the worst and
it's so high maintenance I have to put
oil in it and you don't feel bad that
you're beating up your pillowcase not at
all because I don't smell the way you
you take two showers every day yeah and
your side of the bed is not only
yellower I don't even know why it's
[__] yellower and it stinks it is
yeah
yellower and it stinks so [__]
bad how come I take two shots of the day
that's crazy I know do you scrub are you
scrubbing nah I mean technically I have
built-in calluses so it goes yeah it
doesn't work like that dude um
especially when they get wet those
things get soft who smells worse your
head or my head
I mean I can't smell my own head I could
smell your head and your head's pretty
nuts especially on the side where
there's no [__] hair isn't that weird
like I would understand where there's
hair because like you and I both have
[__] thick set of hair and a lot of
it
um that I would understand that it would
smell there's more hair because like
it's just capturing sweat dust all of
that [__] oils
um
what was the question
like oh why don't I take showers okay
yeah so for my hair it's super high
maintenance right so bleach breaks off
really easily like I can't put too much
heat on it like even the sun will [__]
it up so I have to get like UV oil half
the oil that ends yeah wow even this
hair tie like I'm not even really
supposed to be wearing this hair tie I
should be wearing like a fluffier one
just so it doesn't break my hair or just
even even keeping it like it's just a
big Fiasco so that's one two when I'm in
the shower it's a whole thing I don't
know how to take a rinse the way you
know how to take a rinse you go like oh
I just wet my body and I get out that's
nothing to me that's just disgusting why
is that disgusting because all you did
was just move the dirt from one part of
your body to the other part of your body
no you move the dirt from one part of
your body to the drain no you don't yeah
you do your body is has oils on it bro
yeah it you the the dirt and all of that
[__] sticks on your oils how much are
you dousing canola how much boiler are
on is on you I mean enough for it to not
be clean
you can't tell me you feel the same
amount of clean when you use soap versus
when you don't no that that's the only
amount of clean I need no you don't need
it do we did we not just have the
conversation about the bed you ever wash
your hands without soap uh yeah but it
doesn't feel clean and that's a
different type of skin too anyway so um
when I'm in there I have to like do the
exfoliation type of scrub you know that
scrubber I have in there that there's
only one person that uses it even though
it's there for everybody yeah me yeah um
so I do that and then I shave everything
head to toe like I'm a [__]
dolphin just because I don't like hair
okay
um then I'm cleaning everything yeah
like I have a soap for every single part
of the body yeah the face soap the
[__] head soap I have like a scalp a
minted [__] scalp thing that you use
only like once a month you just said it
was four times a month [__] off you said
two times a week that's even more yeah
so too yes you do yes you're not
supposed to use it I don't see it I mean
it's there is it yes what is it called
um I don't even know but it's like a
Summer's Eve type of deal oh
um so yeah uh do that scrub
it's a whole thing so I'm in there a
minimum 15 minutes minimum okay once I'm
done you can't spare 15 minutes every
single day hold on once I'm done now I'm
[__] in Antarctica you know like I
have to keep the door closed because
that's where all the moisture is I see
as soon as you slightly crack that door
open all of the Antarctica air is coming
into my hot sauna bath even when we live
even though we live in Vegas absolutely
dude it's California it's a freezing 40
39 degrees right now okay it's freezing
like I'm about to [__] see why I want
to change that whole area
um so then once I get out now it's the
moisturizing routine yeah so I have to
moisturize my hair run the oil through
my hair do that whole thing right that's
even that I have to even let it towel
dry because my hair is so thick it takes
for it takes honestly if I was to let it
air dry it takes a full day especially
the back part where I have like the most
dense amount of hair because
everything's on it okay that's the oil
hair then I have the full body [__]
cocoa butter lotion that you don't even
like the smell so once I do that I wear
another coat of lotion to hide that one
because I'm such a CUNY wife that's very
CUNY [__] off all right
um I do that one and then I moisturize
my face yeah and then I I concentrate on
my tattoos too wow so there's a lot of
[__] so I'm talking about like a 30 40
minute thing every day where i'm like
I'm not doing that [__] I'm chilling I'm
gonna make something simple sound
complicated too
yeah yeah you [__] know yeah yeah you
don't make it sound simple it is simple
you get in the [__] water no you made
something oh you made something so
simple sounds so it's like how do you
brush your teeth well I start with
[__] molar number five and I go in a
clockwise motion for five times then I
go on the horizontal plane on the top
and I just go for [__] five times
yeah but how long does that and then I
go how long to K9 tell me tell me that's
how it's describing it you're taking a
shower how many minutes does that take
you to brush my teeth yeah
exactly mine it's not uh could be two
minutes what is it it's literally a
minimum 30 minutes minimum the whole
process and you can do that every day no
I don't want to I don't need to what the
[__] I need to do for
what do you mean this attitude to be
clean yeah change that change that it's
not changing anyway okay so uh yeah I
would do that I would probably change
your hairstyle too well you would change
it to I don't know it's just something
something more now something more like
tell me I'll do it right now it's so
easy now I don't want you to change like
everything you said about me I'm not
changing like I'm already your ideal
that's it we're done you're already my
ideal but I'm just saying the Indie
Ideal World you would just be more
fashion forward with your like because
we're just here starting with your hair
I shave my head
don't ever do that
okay so we got the head right yeah so
now on the inside of your brain I wish
you were more emotionally intelligent me
too um I wish you didn't take things so
literally uh no I like that
well I'm not asking for your feedback
dude okay fine um and I mean I guess you
said a nice thing about me so I'll say a
nice thing about you even though I know
we're not trying to hurt our feelings
but my feelings are [__] hurt
um
um so I like that you're [__] smart
like that's such a huge turn on I can
Overlook the jagged teeth the [__] up
breath
the uneven skin tone like I could I
could over I could oversee I mean uh
Overlook all of that because you're
really [__] smart okay so now from
like the neck down what if Stephen
Hawkins had like the worst breath
yeah I don't need a genius I just like
where you're at oh
if you call me genius that's not
something that makes my panties wet
right like if you're too smart you can
be socially [__] awkward and you're
just [__] a big weirdo maybe that's
maybe that's what it is maybe that's why
I'm so little is because I'm really
smart and then that's why I'm not
emotionally done maybe maybe I mean but
you're still emotionally dumb and you
take things so literally yeah
um so now from the neck down what time
are we at because you know we're gonna
go we going in no I'm just kidding but
neck down
um I would
I like that you don't have hair so
you're like minimally hairy I really
actually do like that but if I had to go
with your physique I think I would keep
you looking at Sea bomb off season
oh so like pretty ripped
um a little bit more built not even
ripped but just a little bit more built
like a little bit more jumper yummy jump
on gear no I don't because I'm hella
gear I mean probably but I'm just saying
like that like those proportions like a
little bit bigger because remember I'm
keeping you at six four so I don't want
a six four like medium lanky dude
because that just defeats the whole
purpose for me like I like you know me
so I like that
monkey right now no I like the size of
your balls I'll get i'll get a little
bit of trt and just go
a little bubbly yeah yeah yeah I like
bubbly
um I don't want you to get uh uh too
fluffy anymore I'm not gonna get that
and don't get too like lean anymore
either like I just want this like sebum
off season six more really fat for sebum
off season right now that's why you're
not my ideal right now I didn't say this
sebum off season is Lane still yeah he's
still like under 12 I get it yeah okay I
get it
um I'd do that
um I would focus oh kind of going back
up to the the head thing why not now
yeah yeah
um because it just made me think about
your stomach and how you're always
complaining that you're always hungry
you don't shut the [__] up I'm hungry
you're like oh God I'm so hungry I can't
even think so Alpha organism another
thing is I would just work on the
exaggeration yeah I am hungry though I'm
not exaggerating yeah I can't even think
oh I'm so I can't even drive right now
I'm literally like a lion just drive I
can't I'm just so I'm literally a lion
until one of my line [__] go grab me
some food I'm [__] laying there I'm
not moving what was the thing that I was
making fun of you yesterday where you're
like I don't know I don't know right now
and I'm like
because you made it sound like you were
dying I think you had like a headache or
something and I asked you like whoops
the most simplest question
you do it so much yes so you got you got
a little [__] little head cold or I
don't know what you had
um and you're just like ugh I just I
can't I can't I probably can't anything
probably told me to like do the dishes
or something I'm like I can't do
anything
oh really [__] I'm like I bleed
for seven days every [__] month I
created a human and for in my body for
nine months my oh yeah you can't handle
this one little thing I was going in it
felt so good what was it so yeah the
exaggeration probably wanted me to like
vacuum or some [__] I'm like I can't do
that
so that's one thing I would do okay so
uh what else
um there I love your hands yeah I think
you have the best hands ever thank you I
love your hands uh love the size of your
back
oh I mean we can go a little bit bigger
but yeah neck love the thick neck let's
not lose that [__] it's not too long
I can't do a guy with a long neck that's
just weird to me if it's long it just
better be girthy as [__] like I just
want a I just want a box you know what I
mean yeah yeah I want a box dude yes
um okay so from the waist down
um I would probably work on evening out
the 10 because your ass is so pale
versus your legs like your legs look
like
um you go outdoors and stuff like you
you grew up on the islands of Hawaii
yeah and then your ass looks like you're
from a Scandinavian country
I need to go 10 huh yeah I I would do
that
um I would focus on like because you
have like a lot of like pimple scars
yeah what the hell are those weird I
don't even know what they are
what are you asking me for I don't know
I can't relate I don't have any of that
I don't look back there I should
probably get some ointment right and
like even out the skin I guess so but
yeah I do like an even skin tone yeah
um so yeah starting from the face it's
even that out your your top half is cool
this area right here where there's like
no man's land like let's let's work on
that how do you work on that
I don't know I'll stand it up I would
keep you more groomed too like in the
I'm shaved down there I mean but
consistently oh I see yeah yeah like
keeping it consistently like a size
maybe maybe like a maybe like a one you
know like a little fade I don't like
when it's too bald because that's just
weird to me I just feel like it's like
some adolescent balls and I'm like ew
like I want a man just five o'clock
shadow all the time yeah yeah that's
pretty hot
um
yeah what else would I change oh your
feet oh my God your [__] feet they
don't smell but I would much rather
trade your [__] I would much rather
have smelly feet that look good then
your [__] Jesus feet dude really I
don't give a [__] they're disgusting you
have calluses that are like three inches
I earned them I can walk on anything and
feel comfortable yeah congratulations I
mean it's not making me wet it's not
making me
I'm changing your brain that these are
gonna make that make you wet I like the
hands that are rough not the feet I'm
gonna make these no make you wet in your
brain change that right now nope nope
nope nope nope nope I want rough hands
if my man has [__] hands that are soft
are my hands rough yeah I love it I love
it I love when you're trying to caress
me and you're [__] tearing up my skin
I'm like [__] yeah that's what I'm
talking about because if your hands are
soft yeah as mine or softer yeah we're
having a problem we're finding we're
gonna [__] go and scrap in the front
yard because they can only be one you
know so I like that you have Man Hands
thank you um but your feet it's I can't
I can't I got man feet though no you got
disgusting third world country no imma
caress your body with my feet don't you
[__] come near me with those [__]
nasty ass feet I like I honestly earn
these and I'm not I'm not I'm not giving
them you said you were gonna do it for
me last time I'm gonna go get a pedicure
instead that's what you said last year
too I said I said you booked the
appointment I'll go with you you can't
laugh though while they're doing it
tickle if I can't help it yeah
it does it is that falls along the being
exaggerated what it's so sick suck it up
suck it up dude I can't suck that up I'd
rather than punch me in the mouth suck
it up
um yeah you have crazier feet than
[__] my dog Mia
like Mia's feet are perfect they're like
she's got this cute little nail that's
we got similar feet where it's like
rough rough in the right places no hers
don't get caught on the carpet the way
you do man so your feet are super
disgusting
um and then you have the fungus nails
like bro let's fix those yeah I got
those in boot camp and I can't get rid
of them yes you can how I don't know
there's prescription there's ointments
there's different treatments you can do
it all right I'll try yeah so you got
that and then you don't ever clip your
nails and they're always so long I'm
like dude can we I always clip them
nails like once every three weeks no
that's already too late it should be
like once a week every Monday make it
make it a thing
every Monday when you're shaving let's
do the whole thing you know yeah that's
true I'll do it like every once a month
shower that I take I do the whole thing
that's true you're right okay like you
don't see my nails going crazy my
toenails going crazy like it just it
doesn't happen that's true yeah we could
do that
um in terms of like the physical part
like the inside Parts
um you wouldn't have asthma I would love
to not have acid you would not have
asthma you would not have the allergies
oh I would love to not have that uh you
would not have like the [__] itchy
eyes where you're just like [__]
doing this thing and and like always
[__] bleeding all the goddamn time I
haven't bled in like [__] a long time
yeah congratulations but that's not the
[__] history that we've had here yeah
sure I always have a place there's like
at least 2 000 videos of a [__]
tissue in your nostril so yeah my ideal
guy would not have that
um yeah my ideal guy would not have the
asthma or the like any of those things
that just slow a human down like you
just yeah you just you can't be worse
than me I I would I wouldn't want those
either I would like to get three of them
yeah yeah you can't be worse than me
luckily you got the eye surgery but that
would have been another one where I'm
like no no no no no me too if I go if I
could swap my eyeballs out I would yeah
um but then I got them so I could see
everything really good yeah yeah and I
guess you always have like this one
nostril that's always [__] growing
and you're constantly digging in your
nostrils it's wisdom because
I mean we got to get rid of rid of the
wisdom all right
um so yeah I think that would be my
ideal
okay it's mainly physical because all of
like the mental maturity
um all those other things like you it's
unlocked it's so solid for sure but just
a couple physical things here that we
can all change so what what do we do
what do we do we we don't have to do
anything we'll trade right here we'll
trade right now right here right here no
we don't have to shake on it we'll shake
on it I'll jump on the gear if you take
away the [__] the [__] is here to stay
all right you got to take the good [__]
with the bad [__] okay the bad [__]
what's the good [__] the good [__] is
the one that's on your side fighting for
you
Australia see what I'm saying we get
what we want that's true when when I
can't handle something on the phone you
go there yeah you get you don't you
throw the [__] big guns up yeah no I
don't care
all right like I don't go off I don't
get crazy I'm not classless that's true
but we get it done yeah yeah you know
what I'm saying yeah and they listen to
chicks way more than this resume
absolutely you know what is that other
phone what the [__] it's you bro Jesus
there you go who is this did anyone even
[__] important no all right cool
um so yeah uh uh that's you got to take
the good with the bad
okay okay so what what are you trying to
do now you were trying to set something
you were like I'm gonna shake on what I
thought we're gonna trade we're gonna be
like okay maybe I'll do my feet if you
do your thing and then I'm surprised you
didn't bring up like my physical form I
love your physical form really I'm so
flabby and gross
I mean that's your own personal like
take on it diet choices
um that's something you can change oh
but I'm just saying you're ideal like
for me remember the the sebum off season
oh I guess I'm just nicer than you but
yeah I mean you could be five percent
body fat less oh like that yeah that
would be cool and then my like I think
my
um life happiness would be so much
higher
no it wouldn't yeah I'd be like
because the [__] is still there I mean
like we were saying I lose my eyes at
least my eyes feel better
all right
uh what if I didn't have boobs would
that be an issue
that'd be very sad yeah yeah because I'm
gonna take them out soon I know I'm very
sad very soon no for real be for real
I'd be I'm for real really yeah it's
that big of a deal for you I like them
but but for you
yeah yeah I mean obviously it's my
choice it's yeah yeah I understand so
the way that I view it is right now I
love you for me
but then if you take them out I love you
for you
okay you know what I'm saying yeah yeah
yeah yeah I get it I get it so it's like
if that's what you want to do
go ahead I'm happy that you're doing it
and I'm sad got it yeah but if you
didn't then I'm happy for the both of us
yeah I get it I get it that's it that
that would be your ideal yeah what about
like um as a mom or as like a wife or
like there's nothing else
attributes no I think are perfect
for you yeah there's CUNY thank you all
right can we talk about some nice things
because [__] I'm about to go I just told
you I'm about to shave my hair I'm about
to make a dentist appointment and just
get everything refilled do it you're
into that kind of [__] anyways I really
am I know I just haven't had the time
give you the time
I like I like I'm gonna have no [__]
facial I'm gonna do the botox again but
just with someone else I like scars and
[__]
you know what I mean no scars what do
you mean we talk about like I think
that's what we're really different I
think that's what we're really doing we
always wipe your nose like a [__]
[__] you I don't know I think I think I
think that's where we're different where
I think you want perfection
and then I think in a lot of ways I like
scars I don't want Perfection it's just
I see myself as like a painting right
like I'm like this yeah and I'm just
drawing what I find beautiful yeah and
you're constantly updating the painting
yeah but it's not a problem I like
patina what's patina you know what
patina is so like um like let's say
vintage watches right like a vintage
rolly
the face used to be white but through
age it's now slightly yellow
and people prefer the patina than to get
it restored uh or same thing with like
when people have vintage cars
there's you can buff out all the paint
or some people like that like some parts
turn turquoise and they keep the patina
it's like a natural aging process like
like I call the scars I think that's
like a brand new leather jacket versus
old leather jacket the older leather
jacket tells a story I like that I'm not
trying to hide the Aging yeah
um I'm just trying to
um keep things consistent right so if
for example the teeth right so I would
want to change all of that because
that's not a consistent flow of what
it's supposed to look like would you
give veneers
um considering the maintenance on it
probably not because they shave all your
teeth that was [__] crazy yeah
um I don't have an issue with my teeth I
think my teeth are fine yeah um it's
just like the fillings and all of that
and now with the technology because back
in the day you didn't really have the
option right or it was probably too
expensive but now they can match it to
your actual tooth color
there is the argument that it's not as
strong or whatever and it tends to crack
faster who knows I've never seen
anything like that I've seen everyone
that I see that has veneers one I can't
even tell them how many years the
feelings I'm talking about the feeling
um because of the right now they use
like this what is it like this metal
some sort of metal yet yeah so they use
a metal to like pack it yeah so now they
would break that and then they fill it
up with like some like um
um not silicone but some type of
material that looks exactly like teeth
so it's just White
um but yeah they say that it's not as
dense or as strong as the metal feelings
but then there's also side effects to
the metal flings I don't know but I
would want it to all look consistent the
same way that's why I would probably be
not probably but I would like bleach my
teeth again so it's all one color
because why don't you just give veneers
nothing gets more perfect than veneers
because it's maintenance right so
anytime I alter my body now that's
something I have to maintain like you
have to maintain veneers um I mean
you're you're weary of certain things
that you eat now certain things that you
drink barely no I don't know but it's
there something I don't want to see
jawbreakers every day girl I was about
to say girl do you not know me I [__]
love candy yeah so do the other veneer
people
um I don't know it's just I if I don't
have to put something synthetic again in
my body or fake or alter it I would
prefer that that's literally what you're
doing when you [__] put fillings in
or whatever yeah but that's I don't have
a choice like if I had a choice I'd be
like no let's just not do that at all oh
but if I if I had it if I don't have a
choice then I'm just gonna make the best
out of that decision
I mean um even with my hair like I feel
like I look too young to have gray hair
and I don't want it like I either want
it to all be gray or I want it to all be
natural hair color like I don't like
this in between when I get more gray
hair I'm for sure going to let it grow
out and just have like the salt and
pepper deal and it's going to look tight
as [__] and I can't wait till that
happens but until then I'm gonna dye it
um
um so yeah
so I'm not trying to I'm not trying to
chase Perfection I'm trying to chase
branding
I see yeah so I want the appropriate
yeah
that makes sense yeah all right what
about for you I like scars
I just like I like [__] that has stories
so for me I think that's like my
branding you know that's why I always
say like if like
um I wouldn't want taika to like take a
permanent Mark and just start marking on
my desk but if he did if he did it'd
make me very happy do you remember that
one time when my whole laptop was
covered in purple permanent marker yeah
it's crazy that a lot of it rubbed off
but I actually really enjoyed it like I
never was like felt a need to
um wipe it off yeah I was mad that he
mocked up my laptop but then after that
it had a story and I just liked keeping
with it yeah so I like I like that you
know do you like scars on your body
I was talking about your ass your ass
scars and you're like oh yeah I don't
like it either yeah those ones don't
look good well okay so then explain that
because it's the same thing with me
that's a little bit different because I
didn't earn them
like those ones are like you earned them
somehow your body did something I earned
my feet okay but like my scars it's like
a difference between like a bullet hole
versus like
I don't know
yeah I just didn't look good I guess so
you're saying you earned a bullet hole
no no I was trying to think of an
example but I couldn't think of the
other example um
here
okay so it has to have a meaning for it
to uh for it to be like something you
want to cherish and preserve to keep it
yeah yeah like my teeth are Jagged yeah
that's good I've been a bunch of street
fights as a kid you know so like for me
like it's cool I wouldn't mind getting
veneers like if you're like you just get
veneers together but let's do it I'll
just do it just for fun
but that's not one thing you could do
for fun that's irreversible yeah but
yeah we do it for fun irreversibly but
um aside from that like you think my
teeth are Jagged but I think my teeth
are dope because they tell the story of
my teen teenage years yeah yeah yeah I
got a bunches paint it that way I'm not
like you can't throw it like that all
right you should rephrase that like what
um um yes I think they're Jagged but
we're speaking in terms of Ideal okay
well I'm not talking about you I'm not
talking about you I'm talking about
anybody anybody that looks at my teeth
is like oh this will have some Jagged
ass teeth I'm like well it's because you
don't know the story behind yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's what I mean not
just you I'm talking about you as in the
public I see yeah okay cool like I have
my own understanding of them which is
why for me they're my teeth are adorable
versus to a dentist they're like what
the [__] your teeth are [__] even when
there's all these stains in between them
and stuff that's adorable yeah
[Laughter]
and why are you against putting [__] on
your face
don't like that greasy feel you want to
know what my mom's regimen was I think
that's just trauma probably okay tell me
so my mom used to get pawns you know
ponza brand
um it's like a face cream brand just get
pawns and then she would get Vaseline
and she'd mix it together and then she
put on my face and why I don't know and
every day I went to school and I could
[__] barely see how [__] grease in
my eyes and [__] and I think from since
then I was just always like just get
[__] away from me like I don't like the
feeling of any grease or anything like
that
on my face at all the closest thing is
CeraVe the uh lotion brand they have
been like the thinnest that I've ever
felt and they're okay like if I feel
like my face is really gonna crack then
I'll get just a little bit of servy and
then put it on there's a lot of it that
you can't even feel so you know that um
I could feel all of it it's just yeah
because you're probably not used to it
but you do get used to it eventually but
there are some super light
things that you could put on your face
so like you know that SPF or the
sunblock that I put on you that's like
this really thin oil base it's just kind
of silky yeah there's those products I
could feel that still yeah barely though
is what I'm saying yeah so you're gonna
feel it the most because you've never
had anything on there but like give it
do that for like a couple weeks it's
nothing now I also like being natural as
much as possible what would Define
natural you just were talking about
[__] getting on DRT I know but I
haven't been on it but I'm talking about
Natty like I'm full on that you don't
even use lotion that's how Natty I am
you probably should start yeah yeah so
you look ashy as [__] start some trt
maybe get some natural oils up in my
face no you look ashy as [__] for sure
and like you're in my arms yes for photo
shoots so the way you get yourself ready
for a photo shoot is how you should be
in regular life
well I don't like Ashley for a photo
shoot yeah but you want to look at you
in regular life look you're so itchy you
would minimize how much you're
scratching too yeah you sure about that
no I don't know you have ADHD so
probably not
no that was just itchy because I was
itchy and then you'd probably have a lot
more socks let me see the bottom of that
sock no wait let me see the bottom of
that sock
that one is ripping too let me see the
bottom of that sock okay can we please
show the [__] camera this is all of
his [__] socks because you're you're
[__] calloused ass feet the heel
specifically is so gnarly you don't have
any socks left I hope you understand
that well it's because my feet nobody
nobody can hang that's how buff they are
yeah so why even wear socks then dude
why even wear shoes
because my wife told me to [__] it don't
wear shoes anymore be the barefoot guy
no I like shoe store they look kind of
cool make up your mind what is it I do
Barefoot a lot because that's not Natty
Barefoot around the house and I would
but that's a lot of people some places
don't even let you in you know that yeah
but if you're gonna be Natty Go full
Natty then don't even wear clothes
that's how that's how I do it at home
you wearing clothes at home
what do you mean a homages in underwear
not these days well it's kind of cold
right now oh so you admit it it is cold
so I'm not tripping it's not like we
live in [__] not Antarctica like
you've been saying I know I'm it's it's
a bit baby it's a bit is it it does it
does really feel really cold though like
right now I'm really like I have a runny
nose because I'm like really cold
yeah I guess I have poor circulation I
don't know what it is okay
but yeah
besides all of that and this is all
jokes I understand
um you're pretty ideal for me that's
Kenny I don't want to be CUNY
oh
what what do you mean it's CUNY fine
it's CUNY but yeah you are pretty ideal
I can over like all of these things that
even you're pointing out about me they
don't mean [__] like it's whatever like
we can get this done in like [__] and
there's stuff that I've just lived with
you know [__] off you poor baby
it's so superficial like all this [__]
right like the cavities the showers the
face the attitude problem hey take the
good
with the bed all right take the bad with
the good you just have to take it right
because it do you think there's an ideal
person out there for everyone
like a hundred percent
no because like because we've been
together for 15 years this year right
um and we're not even each other's ideal
yeah we're not so do you think well
because there's so many like things to
to check off right like I think there's
ideal in different aspects so it's like
that since there's different buckets of
your ideal
um you just have to pick your important
buckets so what is that what true love
is finding the C and falling in love
with the sea and making it making it a c
plus in your brain I take that approach
with my last boyfriend where I thought
because I didn't believe in true love I
just I believed in buckets and going
okay what are the important buckets can
I have it all yeah
um
I don't think you can have it all or
maybe this is just me in denial but so
because I was like I don't believe in
you know love and all that [__] like I
think you just find your ideal or not
even ideal but I just you find a good
match and then you kind of grow into
love and I was doing that with my
previous relationship or I'm like okay
you know I might have to settle here or
this is you know phenomenal here
um and now it just didn't it ain't it
it ain't it but
I I think the idea of even thinking of
what your ideal is is very limiting also
right because you haven't met anyone in
the world like every single person in
the world you don't know their story
like you only know yourself in your town
and your immediate vicinity and that's
so limiting so when does the search end
or does the search continue forever so
for me the ideal partner you know so
there's things that are going to be
fleeting that don't matter
and that would be the physical for me
because we're changing every single day
yeah so for me to put so much emphasis
on the physical when I know it's going
to change later down on the line is
already a recipe for me being absolutely
miserable you're going to get wet too
though
for sure you want to be attracted but
lucky for men women don't really that's
like one small aspect of what makes them
wet that's true it's it's a lot of other
different types of stimulation what
makes you wet the most
um so a guy that's 6'4 is like Jack like
sebum off season I'm just kidding
um naming all the right things yes so
when it comes to my ideal they're the
things that
um will allow for growth in the
relationship so like the things I look
for is someone that is constantly
striving for
um like just being just evolving like
someone that just wants to continuously
learn and grow and and try new things
because I can be with the hottest
[__] but then if he's just stale
and stagnant in life and just with
himself that's so unattractive it could
be he's perfect already so he doesn't
need to evolve anymore he's a shark you
know the shark hasn't evolved in like
thousands of years but we change like
circumstances are already perfect
circumcision circumstances change people
change like we're not a shark yeah you
know what I mean like we interact with
so many things we're not in survival
mode all the time yeah yeah so there's
an ideal for sure but I don't think the
physical parts really
hold much weight for me at least so like
you're my ideal because you're someone
that
um is smart seeks knowledge seeks you
know Evolution like self Evolution
exploration
um so if you were someone that just was
easily complacent and passive and like
that you're not my ideal at all so those
are that's why I'm like when it comes to
like what we're talking about
I don't know I guess there's ideas for
people that's just not my ideal yeah
like I don't care about the physical
stuff clearly
I'm still talking [__] do you do you
think there's ideals I don't know I I
don't know unless I said do you think I
I really to be honest
I might have a really different approach
on things
I really think love is what's in your
mind
that's what I think I think I'm old
school
love is what's in your mind yeah what do
you mean like how you perceive love how
you give love how you receive it
um I think so the way that I see it is
I'm I'm super old school so I'm saying
like take this back to maybe even like
the 1100s maybe old school where I think
um
people spend time searching for love
but I don't think love is external I
think love is internal
so this is what I think
you know how some people don't love
their car until it's like Colombo
right some people have a 1993 Toyota
Camry and they're in love
so to me it's like it's not really about
the other it's about themselves and I
think how much they are able to love
their circumstance is really how much
they love themselves
um I see
so in that regard I think someone that
is full
can probably make it work with any
partner
and a person that isn't full will you
will see have multiple partners and
every single partner is the problem yeah
yeah
yes
that is really complicated
um I do agree with that because
obviously that's like the age-old saying
right like you can't love anyone until
you can love yourself because clearly
you're not going to know what love even
is right because you're going to be
putting it on external factors and when
these external factors change because
that's what life is it's constant change
and you change of course
um then that there then that's when
they're the problem right because you
love them at this phase point in time
but you didn't or you love them but you
don't even know what that even means
because what I look for in a high school
ideal partner would not be the same that
I look for now of course and then who I
look for now would not be
what would make my high school self
happy yeah
um I guess that's what I was alluding to
too when I was saying that
um focusing on the physical is one thing
I wouldn't even look at because we're
changing and just like the life
experiences and all that so I would look
at specific qualities that I value
um that I you know love and cherish and
and
hold at a high standard and then that's
when that I guess I would find my ideal
because I guess I I would want to match
it with
um
just values honestly I think just I
think there is an ideal then just
matching values yeah values is pretty
important huh yeah I think it's mainly
values and then the idea of like you
just knowing
one just being grateful like having
immense amount of gratitude and then
just really loving yourself because how
many people have we talked to where
we're like damn this person does not
know how to even love themselves yeah
like a ton like we were those people
yeah
and it's crazy like it really does start
with self I follow some of those Health
self-help people yeah and they talk
about like repeating affirmations
some of them I don't really agree with
were the ones are like
um like tell yourself how great you are
every day in the morning right or in the
in the mirror but I do like the ones
where they're like remind yourself of
things you're grateful for
you know like things could always be
worse
so if you things could always be worse
and you know that you should be happy
with what you have now because if you
have a I wish things were better
attitude you're never going to be happy
right you're ungrateful well that's that
whole thing right where people are like
if you're seeking happiness you're never
going to be happy yeah
I do like it where it's just like every
morning you wake up and you name three
things that you're grateful for yeah and
then it just fills you with joy and you
get to like approach life and I think
um
that might be one thing that could help
keep a lot of relationships together
more too because rather than going oh is
that my ideal partner or my ideal
partner doesn't have this or my current
partner doesn't have this I need that
but then but what is in this
relationship that's beautiful and then
zoning and living in that world more
maybe yeah that affirmation scene that
you brought up
um I do see value in it because I know
that there's people that have
experienced crazy amount of [__] or
they're just in a different darker place
that's true some people need it you know
where they're that in the depths of it
where they don't even value themselves
yeah but they have to like pull
themselves out and be like wait you're
also worthy you're also a good guy or
good girl and like you do offer
something in this world you know so I do
see value in that it just doesn't apply
to us because we're not there yeah
that's true you know we're we're at the
point more where it's be present be
grateful like what are you know three
things that you're grateful for or
whatever and I do agree that
um
a lot of it like
a lot of it does come when from within
because that's also going to determine
who your partner is or who you spend
your time with regardless if you have a
partner or not or and how you're going
to spend your time so like when I would
do you know q and A's and stuff on
Instagram and people would be like hey
that this person just broke up with me
or how do I get over a broken heart or
how do I do this
I was always trying to find different
ways to say like because it's always the
same thing I'm always going to say the
same thing of like or just work on
yourself like what what would you love
about yourself that you don't have at
the moment like do that and then you're
just gonna not like people will
naturally gravitate towards happy people
happy complete people right like how
many times do we see it like there's so
many people that gravitate towards us
because we're pretty confident happy
um content like filled people and we
attract a lot of different people around
us you know because like we've heard it
time and time again people tell us like
man you guys fill fill my cup up you
know like when I'm around you guys like
it just feels so good and it's because
we've done the [__] hard work and we
continue to do the work because it's not
something that just stops like you don't
just you're not just like good I've
reached my destination here I am I'm
everything I want it to be like it
doesn't work like that it's just
constantly going like
um
like I don't like this about myself or I
did this thing I [__] up here okay
cool it's where's the lesson what's that
Latin saying
what is it what's uh the love of Faith
Like Loving your fate like falling in
love with your fate oh I've never heard
of that one yeah I'm I'm more I'm more
Fati I think it's the Latin phrase yeah
but basically it's just saying with
whatever you're given just like
finding the silver lining in that or
like finding the lesson and that and
like so that it's it's bad for that
moment but now you're able to extract
like the life lesson and then just the
wisdom from it and now you've just
learned and became like a different
version of yourself yeah I think it's a
morive Fati or something yeah but I love
that because I think
um yeah once you're once you're able to
like really love yourself understand who
you are in that chapter of life you just
start attracting different quality of
people like just different experiences
too like it's wild like I always say
this and I always feel so kooky saying
it because I genuinely believe it but
the world it feels like the universe
really wants you to win
you know and the universe gives you
whatever it is that you're like thinking
about and by Universe I don't mean like
where our planets and [__] where
we're at like I'm thinking about like
your head you know like that is your
Universe like your thoughts whatever you
repeat whatever you tell yourself
whatever you consume that is your
universe so if you're consuming super
empowering things following super
empowering people hanging out with
people that are discussing ideas and
just different thoughts and surrounding
yourself with all of that stuff then
yeah your different opportunities that
you're seeking like subconsciously now
you're like looking for it and you start
finding them what does that call it
Manifest Destiny or something is that
what it is or no
I don't know like the one that tripped
me out the most recently was we pulled
taika out of school because of his
seizures and the medication that it
causes and like you know like he has all
kinds of side effects yeah and the new
school that we put them in the his new
teacher her daughter gets seizures I was
like what the [__] wild right this is a
crazy Universe because we were like all
like walking on eggshells so he doesn't
get seizures you have to do it don't
worry I got it my daughter gets seizures
too so I know exactly what to do we're
like oh my God that's so cool yeah I
mean it's not so cool that his daughter
gets seizures no it's cool there's
someone that he's in the right hand yeah
yeah yeah I was just like what that's
been my whole life though yeah like my
whole life has worked out like that
um where I I've never really been in a
state of panic ever where I'm like you
have a stinky head and I have hater
blockers in my nose so he got really
lucky see what I'm saying because any
other guy would have kicked you to the
curb a long time ago yeah see what I'm
saying yeah they wouldn't but I didn't
kick you through the curbside I could
barely smell it I'm way too awesome but
then by the time I smell it I'm so
[__] awesome I enter your life and
immediately your bank account grows
you're thick your [__] dick gets
bigger it did get bigger as you see your
career skyrockets like I am how big did
he get it started and then it was like
no no no I mean I'm not [__] Jesus
Christ
um but yeah the [__] golden um
can you shut up
that's what I am all right
but yeah no I do agree that for sure it
all starts with self
and it is like you're saying Love is in
the mind
um yeah because if you don't know if you
don't even understand the depths of love
that's just as deep as your [__] love
is gonna go whoa Mia
yeah
anyway on that note thank you for giving
me a new [__] I don't care about
everything you said I am your ideal
you're [__] crazy gray hairs are dope
feelings tell a good story even though
you hurt my feelings I like your salt
and pepper teeth
you're so stupid do you have anything
else to add yes what
like what it said in the King James
version of the Bible oh those
with two hands must take a shower every
once in a while now they don't that's
the you know
in that area they're nasty
anyway on that note thank you so much
see you guys next week bye